- Where's Brianne?
- Right here, hi!
- [Kelly] What's up?
Why did you request,
I mean that might be a top two favorite,
like she's got so many hits, Reba.
"Why Haven't I Heard From You"
is one of my favorite jams to sing.
Why'd you pick it though?
- I picked it because, my
mom is my best friend, Linda,
and she's completely selfless,
she volunteers thousands
of hours in her community,
and she was diagnosed with
terminal breast cancer
and given two years,
and that was four years ago,
so she's still with us!
(audience claps)
She's raised us kids and I promised her
that when she beats it, we're
gonna take her to see Reba,
and that is a goal of ours.
She's really sick, so having you sing it
is the next best thing because
we absolutely love you--
- [Kelly] Aww!
- and so thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Did you say
she was given two years
and it's been four?
- [Brianne] Yes.
- She's one hell of a fighter.
- Yes, she absolutely is.
- That's a beautiful thing,
four years and they gave
her two, she's got this.
- We had a couple of close calls,
but she's been good.
- Come on up here, come on up here.
(crowd cheers and claps)
- [Brianne] Thank you so much!
I love it, thank you.
- I was expecting like,
I don't know a fun thing,
and that's not a fun thing, I'm so sorry!
- She's fun, she's fun.
- I know she's fun, but that's
just, that's a heavy thing.
- Yeah.
Well, tell me a little bit
more about your mom though,
like why is she such a big Reba fan?
- She's just always raised
us on country music,
and growing up...
in the car, at home, she's
always played Reba for us.
So we've just always
grown up with the music,
and she's huge on country,
so I'm huge on country,
huge on Kelly!
And so just you singing
it was so big for her.
- Okay, well I love your mom.
- She's awesome!
- So, what's your mom
like, is she fun like you?
- Oh, she's tons of fun.
I can tell you stories,
but they're probably not
appropriate for here.
(laughing)
But we've gone to Vegas--
- Oh my gosh, I love her.
- For her 50th, and we have
get-togethers at the house
and she hosts all the
holidays and all the parties.
- [Kelly] Oh, she's a light!
- She's so much fun.
Even though she's sick,
she makes sure that she's
the life of the party
as best as she can be.
And she still does everything
for everybody else,
even though she's going through
what she's going through,
everybody else comes first.
(clapping)
- That's a beautiful mom.
- She's awesome.
- Alright, I'm honored you
said I'm the next best thing,
you know, to Reba, but I think
your mom deserves the best
so please welcome country
legend, Reba McEntire!
(crowd cheers and claps)
- Shut up!
Oh my god!
(upbeat happy music)
I was not expecting that!
Oh my gosh, hi it's so nice to meet you!
Oh my gosh, you're amazing,
you're so beautiful!
- Tell your mama hi for me, okay?
- I will! You're so
beautiful, thank you so much.
- Come on over here, and
you stand in the middle.
Reba, you come on over here.
Alright so--
- [Brianne] You are so amazing, thank you.
- Brianne, is there
anything you wanna tell her?
- You are such an incredible motivation
to me, my sisters, my brother, my mom.
I mean, my mom listening to
your music uplifts her spirits.
I mean, her license plate
even says "Survivor"
after your song--
- Great, great!
- and we just, we love
you, so thank you so much
for being that for her, for my family.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, I've
never thought about that song,
how perfect that song is.
(crowd claps)
All right, so since your
mom isn't well enough
to join us today, we're
going to talk to her at home.
Alright, so look in the
camera, and let's give,
what's your mama's name again?
- Linda.
- Linda, we have somebody here
that might wanna say something to you.
- Hey Linda, I'm Reba McEntire,
and I just wanna tell you
that my thoughts, my
prayers, go out to you,
and hang in there girl!
I know you're tough, you
can beat this sucker!
- [Kelly] Yeah, you've
already made it four years!
(clapping)
You've got this!
Well thank you so much Brianne!
- [Brianne] Thank you so much!
- [Kelly] Such a great
song, such a great pick!
- Thank you so much!
- [Reba] Tell your mom "hi".
- [Kelly] Alright let's take a seat ma'am!
That was awesome!
Let's have a seat, okay.
So, for this, this is so weird because,
you know when you're friends and family
with someone and you
have them on your show
it's awkward! (laughs)
I ended up marrying her oldest son and,
and you got stuck with me... more!
- Thank goodness!
(Kelly laughs)
Thank goodness. And I'll
clap for that one too!
(crowd claps)
- [Kelly] I mean, out of
all of the fun we've had,
I always have my little
moments with you because,
I know we're friends and we're family,
but you're always like that hero to me.
- Aww!
- [Kelly] Especially
musically, you're just a beast!
Like a pioneer for women, it's insane!
(audience cheers)
- Thank you.
- And not just musically,
like I think what's amazing
about your career is,
you're a businesswoman, um,
you've conquered Broadway,
you've conquered TV,
you've conquered movies, animated films!
I mean, you've done
everything you could possibly
want to do so my question is,
"What is the next mountain"?
Because, you've done, you've already...
mastered everything! (laughs)
- Well I haven't mastered
or conquered anything--
- [Kelly] Yes you have!
- I've just gotten to participate.
People were nice enough
to let me be apart of,
I'd tell you what I'd really love to do...
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I want to do an authentic Western movie.
Or television show!
- [Kelly] Oh!
- A western.
- People would love that!
- [Reba] I love Westerns, love em!
- Oh my god, there's so many avenues now!
Netflix, Amazon, all the things!
- [Reba] Everywhere!
- We can make this happen!
- Kelly Clarkson said so!
Right there!
(crowd claps)
- [Kelly] Yes, and I think
people would love that!
- I do too. I do too.
- I would love, and this is only because
when I first heard you,
it was a lot of like
Oklahoma, kind of Texas
swing, kind of style?
I would love an old school record!
Like an old school country!
I think that would be amazing!
- Well thanks!
- [Kelly] This is me asking as a fan!
Because my thing is...
That's the kind of country music
that I feel like separates it
from other genres and it doesn't
blur the lines of pop or anything.
It's like that authentic
just story-telling of,
"She Thinks His Name Was
John", or "And Still", or...
just all those songs are so meaningful
and have changed people's
lives, along with Brianne!
Oh by the way, that's my middle name!
I just remembered that!
(audience laughs)
My husband is making fun of me back there
and you know it! (laughs)
Well as promised, I found
some old photos of you.
Are you ready to go through them?
- Oh boy!
- [Kelly] I'm excited, alright!
- Alright, let's see what you've got!
- [Kelly] Here is the first one.
Yes! (laughs)
Oh my gosh, how old are you there?
- [Reba] I think second grade.
- Oh my god, you're adorable!
Look at that, you had that
big old hair going even then!
You were like "Y'all
aren't ready for my hair!"
(Reba laughs)
Okay next... yes!
I mean, it looks like you're about to fall
with the horse but you're not.
- [Reba] Okay two things
about, three things about that.
I've got the reins in the wrong hand.
(Kelly laughs)
That is my brother,
Pake's, calf-roping horse.
He wasn't working too good for Pake,
so Pake said I could run barrels on him.
And I am rocking the plaid pants.
- Yes you are.
Yes you are ma'am!
Fashion icon before it really even hit.
Okay next.
- [Reba] Oh! That day Kelly
I won a car for six months.
- [Kelly] What!
- I won a Ford Torino car for six months.
And all you had to do
was fill out your little
questionnaire thing, and then...
That is the Kiowa Cowboy
high school band right there.
- Oh my god.
- Oh you see the guy on
the right, Roger Wills?
He's the band leader for Alan Jackson.
- [Kelly] Oh no way!
- And then Susie is in the
middle, and Pake on the left.
And Gary Reburn and Kelly Rein.
- Your whole family
sings, that's what I find,
I know that, and I know that
a lot of people do know that.
But it's insane like I'm
talking everyone sings well!
Like it's crazy!
- Well daddy, somebody asked
daddy one time and said,
"Clark, do you play?"
And he said "I used to
play on the linoleum".
(Kelly laughs)
- I loved your dad!
- He's a character, he loved you.
- [Kelly] I love it, okay next!
- Oh my gosh!
- Oh that's Winona--
- And Trisha!-- - Is that Trisha?
- Yeah, Bruce Hinton--
- Whoa!
- Oh my gosh look at Trisha she's so cute!
- [Kelly] Look at your
hair, you are so cute!
Look at all of, y'all are so cute!
- [Reba] When was that?
- [Kelly] I don't know!
You all have, are those records?
- Uh-huh!
- Those are all of your records.
Oh my god this is what I'm talking about!
See, this is 90's country right here!
All of these women representing right now,
and they don't play women
now, hardly, on country.
What's wrong with y'all?
- [Reba] They're missing out.
- I know! Next.
Oh this is us!
- [Reba] That was for the duets album.
- [Kelly] It was!
- [Reba] You came and sang with me.
- It was so magical, it's
so funny because remember
we actually recorded a
different song first?
- [Reba] Uh-huh!
- And then we ended up doing Crossroads,
and then we ended up
doing "Because of You"
and it was such a magical moment.
- [Reba] Kelly, we look so young.
- I know. I still look
good, I don't know--
- [Reba] Oh shut up!
- what you're talking about! (laughs)
Next, oh I was here!
- [Reba] Oh yeah!
- [Kelly] This is the Kennedy--
- [Reba] The Kennedy Center Honors,
thank you for coming and singing for me.
- I will do anything for you ever!
- Thank you, thank you very much.
- This was really awesome.
- It was a lot of fun.
- I generally don't get nervous,
but I'll tell you what...
I about peed my pants at that one.
- You did great!
- [Kelly] I was nervous!
Okay next.
(audience cheers)
Okay ma'am!
- [Reba] Well--
- Is this in Vegas?
- Uh-huh.
- That's in Vegas, oh my gosh.
Next, okay I feel bad about myself.
Oh this is awesome, what's this?
- [Reba] Oh, that's when I
was, no my 40th anniversary
of being in the Grand Ole Opry!
There's Vince Gill, Dolly
Parton, Carrie Underwood.
(crowd claps)
Aw, that's so sweet!
- And you're actually reuniting,
with Dolly and Carrie!
- Yes, Dolly, Carrie, and I,
we are going to be co-hosting
the CMA awards this year!
- I love it!
(audience claps and cheers)
- [Reba] How about that!
- [Kelly] I couldn't think
of three better women!
- [Reba] Thank you!
- To do that.
- Thank you, I'm thrilled
to death that they asked me!
- Yes, I mean what, of
course they asked you!
They were like "We need a legend"!